in my opinion it's just the best fan
film you'll ever see yeah yeah it's a
really great YouTube fan movie that's
what it felt like if someone put
together the Han Solo things you talked
about yeah yeah I'm gonna see those
things yeah we're really nothing
different looks like yeah yeah that's
what the film is so we went to an early
screening of solo a Star Wars story it's
night time for us embargo lifts at a
specific hour though I'm sure we are one
of many reviews that have suddenly been
uploaded in your notification bells for
YouTube and were just one of many just
like how this Star Wars movie is now
just one of many Star Wars movies to
come yeah oh boy and there will be
another and another and another after
that we have to steer very clear of as
many spoilers as possible basically
anything that the trailer doesn't tell
you we cannot tell you anything about
even though if you've seen the trailer
and you have an idea of what this movie
is about it's a pretty predictable
generic film a whole lot of what you
expect yeah it's exactly what you'd
expect it's exactly how we all thought
it would be and and I guess that's where
the disappointing factor comes in
because I don't want to say the word
unnecessary I feel like most films or
unnecessary what film is really
necessary really boil that argument down
only documentaries can really be
necessary yeah but there's a lack of
specialty in here but that's not to say
that movies not fun for majority of it
if you didn't like the darker tones of
like the last Jedi and world one
especially this film really
Upsy Annie I'm just having a fun time
throughout there's no stakes it's a lot
of fun knew that they have
I mean the problem is there's a certain
amount of weight that gets removed from
this movie when you just know that
Dawn's gonna succeed how I'm gonna see
him later like chewy an ensemble you can
take a best guess with all the other
characters you haven't heard what's
gonna happen oh wait to what they're
doing cuz you know that the events
they're gonna focus on or probably not
be successful guess the best way to
start with this is talking about the
cast of course and a guy whose name I
can never remember how to say Alden and
head up starin right I'm not one of
those people who complains about his
performance going I want to see Harrison
Ford in here honestly I just wanted to
see him do his own thing I was able to
strip my mind away from thinking about
Harrison Ford honestly the guy does a
good job although it can be in a minute
for me I think that he's charming he's
funny
you're gonna comparing her Harrison
Ford's no he's not Harrison Ford that's
for sure I felt like his performance was
in her minute cuz it for the most part
of felt kind of OneNote for me although
that note he was playing was a lot of
the time charming his performance can
sometimes ham up the charm there were
times where I thought he was really
hamming up the charisma part he does
that same smile I get every Tom Cruise
smile yeah there are times where I
really liked him two times right thought
he was kind of annoying
overall though he's not boring I was
worried he was gonna be a boring Han
Solo and he's not yeah I feel like the
tricky part about Han Solo for this
movie in general is that by design they
just can't do a whole lot with that
character to surprise you so he's
constantly surrounded by more
interesting characters I don't know who
have other things going on and it's like
I liked Alden Ehrenreich I thought he
was charming but the movie I don't think
they gave him a ton to work with really
beyond just being charming badass
console I don't think this is a spoiler
I don't really think he has an arc in
this movie you know yeah no no I felt
like they could have arced him
especially because he's so different
than who he isn't a new hope well they
made a big deal about that in the
advertising about how he's oh he's young
and starry-eyed got all these dreams
pilot yeah and he does be a pilot the
standout performance is one that I guess
I shouldn't be surprised by I guess what
surprised me was the amount of usage
they took out of him in this movie was
Woody Harrelson
I thought Woody Harrelson was great
pound for pound I think he's the best
performer he's he's definitely the best
performance it surprised me that not
everyone's really talking about him in
their early reactions I think says we
all expect what Harrelson to just kind
of do a good job now you know I still
thought that he had the most fully
fleshed character out of everyone and
his performance feels very lived in and
the most surprises coming yeah yeah
Donald Glover is lando I thought was
very charming there's a lack of land in
this movie yes we're surprising how it's
a little land oh there was there's a lot
in this movie that feels incidental
rather than essential Donald Glover he's
it's fun to watch him as Lando they need
his ship they don't really need him
things like that kind of hamper the
effect it's again I thought he was great
and I wish they gave him something
better to work yeah there's a new droid
that they teased in the movie that is
connected to Lando named l3 some people
it seems like when we're walking at
theater some people were very much not
for l3 and then there are people I had I
think you were I don't go three mile I
liked l3 I mean there's some stuff
that's very on the nose with what they
were doing with her character but I
thought l3 got the biggest laughs out of
me and it was one of the characters with
the most personality yeah and part of
what's fun about these new spin-offs is
the amount of personality they can bring
Paul Bettany as the the main baddie in
the film he was good he's good fine job
he's good he does a good job yeah he's
kind of a generic villain I'm good at
doing this new type of villain that we
have now who's not like quite a mustache
twirler like he's got enough
performance-based nuanced but really
he's just a mustache tor tell her I was
really distracted by the makeup they did
you see it in the trailer there's a
question just movie I couldn't help it
go okay were you trying to go for
subtlety cuz now I'm just distracted
thinking yeah yeah half assed the makeup
you can stretch with yeah it feels
really half-assed when I was watching it
be more creative man he's the main bet
if he can do more things in it Emilia
Clarke
Zeus is fine you see I think the big
issue with this film is it didn't know
where its heart was really at yeah this
is when Chewie first shows up and
Chewy's cool
Chuy's cool movie yeah who is mildly
endearing even and when Chewie shows up
I was like oh this is where the heart of
the movies at is Chewie and Leia Han and
you're like just not because it's really
spent much time development and then
Lando shows up eventually and I'm like
oh this is what the movies really trying
to tell you is the heart of the movie
lies within han and Emilia Clarke
character whose chemistry I just cannot
buy yeah I did not buy their chemistry
man honestly I got the most heart from
him and woody harrelson because that
relations yeah like a mentor you meant
yeah I'm him an emilia clark or super
internment and together i don't know how
well they were able to lead this there's
a lack of stakes there's a lack of
emotional impact the movies just aiming
to be fun but I also felt myself kind of
not really invested like you're you're
sharing fun like don't get me wrong
there's a lot of cool spectacle in here
to me the best thing about this is just
visiting the Star Wars without seeing
more parts of that and on that level
it's amazing they use a lot of practical
in this film which I really appreciate
it I'm glad that that's what they've
been sticking with and say broughtest or
Star Wars back with force awakens is
sticking as much too practical as
possible production design is as great
as you'd expect it to be with a Star
Wars film absolutely and there's some
bomb action sequences in here titter
shot really well that the second unit
man hats off like the train sequence is
cool the Kessel run while there are some
people who couldn't really tell what was
going on and there were times where I
was like never really sure but I also
felt the intensity of it so I thought
they pull off the Kessel run pretty well
too and for what that has to live up to
I thought that was a pretty cool seek
was well stylized well choreographed
other than the action sequences that
Billy a lot of this film wasn't really
shot with a specific style or nuance the
only occasional flavor I would ever
catch was Western
sometimes they would have these little
Western I should I'm gonna be like yeah
this movie seems like it maybe wants to
be kind of inspired by a Western the way
like rogue one was inspired by a heist
movies yeah but it's
only ever halfway you're just left with
this kind of template shooting style
yeah it's felt very simplified it's in a
weird way it doesn't have that effect of
watching Justice leaguer you're like
Zack Snyder shot this matter in fact it
feels like Ron Howard probably shot into
the majority of the film it doesn't feel
like it has their hands on it no it
doesn't it like not one bit if you know
the behind the scenes story at all even
this the tidbits you can't help but be
aware there's probably a more special
movie within all of this you know and
it's a bummer because you know that just
the way these movies work I can't
imagine they want to rock the boat that
much but what this movie could use a
whole lot more of its its own
personality and the guys who could have
given it that are those two yeah cuz Ron
Howard is a good filmmaker and this is
like a well made well assembled movie
but it doesn't have the soul or the
quirkiness that two dudes like that
could have brought yeah it just really
felt like there was a level this movie
just was not heading in terms of
personality and style and soul and heart
it's just fine it's yeah it's a it's
fine what were we all saying before we
watch this movie it's probably gonna be
a disposable entertaining Star Wars film
that's exactly what it is so that's what
your expectations are it's gonna meet
exactly that yes it's filler for Star
Wars I don't want to walk out of this
st. it's unnecessary just like give me
something that makes this special like I
thought rogue one even gave that like no
it's not necessary there was stuff about
it that made it special and they made
choices with characters that made it
more impactful and this movie doesn't do
any of that I think the most annoying
aspect of this film is the prequal
syndrome ours yeah I was not expecting
it to be so on the nose with its
references and nothing that he's got it
this is how it happened and this is the
most like on the nose I've seen I
thought we had learned from like all
those horror remakes to be like oh
that's where you got the mask this like
trivial way this movie takes it back to
like oh man you really want us to be
aware yeah and the way we're not having
trouble
things they even repeat man yeah like we
can't spoil I don't want to spoil it
that's what you do experience there are
moments they give to things that I
didn't even realize needed explained
yeah yeah I was like oh cool you made a
moment of how this happened I just
thought that was the way it was if it's
passable disposable Star Wars
entertainment it's not terrible it's not
bad nothing special I give it a sure
yeah all right guys well thanks for
tuning in brew might not be able to see
solo for a while but as though you think
about it when you watch it what
character do you think deserves a
spin-off movie please say r2d2 that
could be cool imagine no dialogue yeah
just beeps and sometimes directed by
Josh Trey you sure Josh Trank and then
halfway through is gonna become a
completely different yeah I'm more
compelled to do a spoiler review about
this than the last Jedi I don't know why
this is more of a fun movie to like pick
apart you guys can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
bell to get notified every time one of
our vids is up you can check us out on
patreon full-length TV show reactions
weekly Q&A is would love to have you
become a patron eject today